[Music]
all right today's question comes from
steven in ohio he says i'm 29 and i work
as a security guard earning a little
over 19 000 this year
i live with my girlfriend and her two
sons and i'm barely keeping my little
family afloat
i'm stressed out because i can't get my
girlfriend to be financially responsible
even though she says she's on board she
voluntarily cuts her work hours leaving
the bills to me the only thing she helps
with is groceries because she receives
food stamps
how do i get her motivated about
budgeting and saving if she won't get on
board should i give up the last two
years with her and these boys
oh man um
brother you are being taken advantage of
and you are financially supporting
somebody who's not invested in you or
this family or their safety and security
and i know that's hard to hear because
it clearly you're you love this person
and you love her kids and you even refer
to them as your little family right now
they're not
you are a
outside participant who has been duped
into paying for everything for everybody
um
yeah this is hard you can't get her
motivated about budgeting and saving
you've tried she's not interested in
that
she's interested in you paying for her
life and her boy's life while she does
whatever she wants to do
um
this is heartbreaking dave
can you um
can someone like her
uh is there a percentage chance she's
brought around with the right scenario
or is this just walking papers
um
i always default to henry cloud's famous
saying which is she needs some problems
she needs some challenges um right now
she's got a guy who's not making hardly
any i mean he's yeah was he just barely
over the poverty line here yeah um he's
struggling security guard work is hard
and it's late nights and it's exhausting
all that and um
i think she needs
and i hate to say that because she's
clearly had hard time she's got two boys
she's got a tough road ahead but
um
i think she's got to recognize oh this
just doesn't actually happen this way
and i'm here here's my guess dave and
this isn't fair because again these
things you never know the full story
here if stephen left there would be
somebody new in relatively short order i
think
and i think steven i just read through
the lines here man it looks like he is
trying and working and thinking and
dreaming
um
but it's got to be heartbreaking yeah so
i mean
a best best-case scenario is he
uh
says okay
the number one thing that breaks up
families and breaks up marriages is
money and money fights money problems
and money fights
and you're having one and you're not
even married
and so um
to see a future of this getting better
without a an abrupt
turn
a u-turn in the behaviors
um
then
then then yeah then you're just kidding
yourself
because let me just tell you if you
gonna make a hundred thousand this
doesn't get better it gets worse it gets
worse it magnifies it and uh reading
this thing he cares more about
this little family than she does well
then then she doesn't know how to she
that's right the tools that's right she
know the tools so i you know if um
i always want to give somebody a shot
always you know so it wouldn't sound
like i'm just done
because you're just too stupid to help
and i'm walking out of here okay so
instead i i
but but i'd also don't want you to live
in denial and four years from now still
be waiting on her change because that's
bs okay but i would say something along
the lines of hey number one thing breaks
up families and we're not even really
technically a family yet there's money
fights and money problems and we got
those and so in order for me to stay
here and in order for us to move towards
marriage and move towards life and me
move into my new career and double my
income
we're going to have to be on the same
page about this and that's going to be
we're going to get this family balanced
and off of food stamps
you're going to be working
and i'm going to be working and we're
going to be living on less than we make
and we're going to be responsible if you
don't want to participate in that then
that's you're saying
no i don't want you here that's right
and that's the price of me being here is
that we're going to be grown-ups and
that's steven looking in the mirror and
saying what do i need like what what
what do i need in my life that's going
to help me see my reflection with
dignity and respect and value and right
now he's trying to get that by solving
everyone else's problems he can't right
so that's him looking in the mirror
saying
that's what i deserve the toxic
horrible old joke is if you're going to
marry a woman who loves spending money
you better enjoy making it mm-hmm okay
and that's you know that's obviously a
you know a
backward horrible joke but especially in
this setting
but uh but i mean you know if you marry
a princess she ain't gonna grow up to be
anything but a princess right if you
marry a guy who's lazy he's not gonna
grow up anything anything but lazy if
you marry these things and so unless
they got to be a change unless they go
they have a moment and they have this
epiphany and sometimes that's an
intervention of sorts that you're saying
it's an ultimatum you're saying
i don't see this going
good going anywhere good 10 years from
today so i'm not going to do this
anymore based on
momentary feelings
now if if we can do these things then i
can change my mind about it going
forward and i think we can go forward
but
even as much as i love you i can't
participate in this anymore and that's
what henry cloud our friend again says
is a necessary ending it's when you lose
hope that the future is going to get
better that's right and
and i think it's important to call this
out he says here at the end if she won't
get on board should i give up the last
two years yeah dave we see this in
investing and we see this in
relationships this sunk cost idea yeah
and i talk to so many people in the
relationships that say well i've got
seven years in and yeah he's verbally
abusive but i've already got seven years
so what do you got another you
what two years are you giving up here
these two years kind of sucked they
sound like they've been really brutal on
you right yeah so yeah bring me yeah
thank you may i have another that's
right no thank you i think i'll pass on
that so i get the investment man but yes
sorry it's not it's not an investment
it's um
it's when you didn't deal with this
earlier is all that two years was
you you did you should have dealt with
yeah you moved in with her you should
you did all this stuff in the wrong
order and you set yourself up for
failure and that's that's where you're
setting today
my heart's broken for both of them man
yeah i i
it would be very cool if they could sit
down
with a marriage counselor with a pastor
and someone guide them through getting
on a long-term vision
for their end quotes little family
that's right so we're going to get
married we're going to both work we're
going to both be responsible we're going
to bring in more income we're going to
model these little boys get this thing
off the poverty line so these little
boys
can can have a better life and we're
going to be grown-ups because what we're
dealing with here is he's got three kids
that's exactly right
making 19 000 a year
man or woman it's not a man or woman
thing it's a child thing adults devise a
plan and follow it
children do what feels good